if you had the choice
who would be your daddy of choice would
it be sir ian mckellen or michael
fassbender
oh
talk about wanda for a second because
you've had a very interesting journey
through with this character from the
very beginning and losing your brother
then vision then your children and all
this
did you know this was all going to
happen
no we we were about to finish filming
one division when i found out what the
what the story was what the script was
it was um verbally pitched to me
and uh i was very
shocked
um and then i was trying to figure out
how what we had left of one division is
there anything i could do to connect
them besides the tag it was i really
just allowed it just to be the tag and
to just focus on one division um and
just how allow the tag to be the only
thing that we tee up
um but no it's definitely a surprise now
when you work with these characters is
it really tough to do this because does
kevin feige say look you've got to
really stay in this sandbox so to speak
can you play a little bit and add some
of your own elements to it no kevin's
kevin really just gives us freedom he
there's no parameters when we make these
films we create our own limits if and
and the script obviously we have to
stick to the script sam was really
elemental in helping me find a tone
with um with the scarlet witch and
doctor strange um part of me wants to
really
lean into to this like delicious
feeling of um being vindicated
and he constantly was reminding me of
her humanity and so it was something
that that we were always trying to play
with levels in that way but it was
really after one division that i've even
not even just with um scarlet witch or
wanda but with other characters that
i've played now there's been um like an
openness of um of playfulness because of
how playful that show was so i i do feel
like that's now part of the process for
me
last question for you here now it's kind
of a fun one in the comics your father
is magneto now multiverse anything can
happen
if you had the choice
who would be your daddy of choice would
it be sir ian mckellen or michael
fassbender
i'm gonna go with sir ann mckellen i had
the biggest crush on him he's in these
videos called playing shakespeare where
he actors get together and they do a
shakespeare um it's a video series
and he's like the sexiest man in the
world
wow and so i would i would say sir ian
mckellen
sparks would fly on that scene i think
[Music]
thank you